en effet manuel macron donc devrait
arriver on a vu un dans la foule voilà
regardez vous le voyez sur l'écran la
scénographie soignée il est accompagné
de sa femme brigitte macron et puis
d'une trentaine de jeunes regardez cette
image du président de la république
réélu la tour eiffel symbole par
excellence de paris connue dans le monde
entier et puis ces jeunes c'est le
message qu emmanuel macron a choisi ce
soir pour son nouveau mandat et bien
c'est d'être entouré de jeunes gens la
jeunesse il l'a répété plusieurs fois
elle a souffert pendant le coc vide
c'est donc eu une image forte qui est
présenté emmanuel macron tout sourire
avec à son bras évidemment la première
dame brigitte macron
il arrive là dans la salle évidemment
tout le monde se tait alors tout le
monde a sorti les téléphones portables
vous pouvez vous en douter et on voit au
loin je sais pas si vous voyez sous un
des piliers de la tour eiffel là on
aperçoit au loin et bien ce convoi du
président de la république de sa son
épouse brigitte macron et puis de ces
jeunes voilà je vous laisse écouter
regarder il y a encore peut-être 50 100
m qui va séparer le président de la
république de la foule de ses militants
continuer de partager ses images avec
les téléspectateurs de nos chaînes
parlementaires et peut-être aussi une
espagne et aux usa chez les commenter il
avait choisi on peut dire thomas qui
rappelle aussi cette arrivée à la
pyramide du louvre et moi soul eater
cinq ans mais les différences sensibles
c'est moins solitaire mais une une
arrivée avec un est différente pour être
honnête parce que il était vraiment un
homme seul le côté jupitérien dans sa
mise en scène de dix à cinq ans la il a
fait le choix d 39 ou et c'était aussi
d'espagne irina chez le dernier mode
sont de sa carte blanche à la fin du
débat me souviens bien mais je crois que
il n'y a pas de doute sur le fait que
nous avons l'intention
d'ouvrir d'ouvrir notre gouvernement
d'ouvrir notre programme je les dis la
question n'est pas de savoir quelles
sont les opérations d'appareils qui vont
se passer ici et là la question est de
savoir quel projet on veut porter et le
projet que nous voulons porter c'est
celui de la social démocratie c'est
celui de beaucoup de maires madame qui
viennent de la gauche et qui nous
rejoignent à territoire de progrès et
c'est une gauche et c'est une gauche et
est un centre droit et un centre gauche
qui assume de regarder les faits tels
qu'ils sont c'est à dire que c'est
jaurès 1 qui qui disait ça qui parlait
de allié idéal et comprendre le réel et
je pense et je pense je ne le conçois
monde et il m'a inspiré comme tout le
monde est là aussi pas de monopole s'il
vous plaît mais un espagnol une action
voit bien qu'à des coalitions qui sont
en train de se dé à lyon 5 5 s est
ouvert à jour jouty qui sont en tout cas
souhaité et 100 ha à droite ou à la
droite de la droite à l'extrême droite
vous nous soumettez dans la magie aussi
parce qu on voit quand même gérard
longuet qui semble assez reproche de vos
idées vous souhaitez aussi
j'ai dit que monsieur emmanuel macron
doute une majorité parlementaire son
intention de voir ces deux-là préparer
parce que sinon il ya un
[Musique]